vamos a evaluar la siguiente integral
trabajemos en esto juntos Pero si en
algún momento ustedes sienten que pueden
seguir adelante solos siéntanse libres
de ponerle pausa a este video y hacerlo
la primera cosa que ustedes pueden notar
aquí es que es una expresión racional y
que el grado en el numerador es el mismo
grado que en el denominador Así que yo
creo que aquí se necesita hacer una
división algebraica Así que tomemos x al
cuadrado para dividir nuestro numerador
que es x al cuadrado más x menos 5
observemos los términos que tienen el
grado más grande Cuántas veces entra x
cuadrada en x cuadrada Pues solo una vez
así que aquí ponemos uno y hacemos la
multiplicación que va a ser uno por x
cuadrada es x cuadrada y 1 * -1 va a ser
igual aquí a -1 Y ahora restamos esta
expresión en verde de esta expresión en
Rosa o podemos sumar el negativo de esta
aquí pongo un menos y menos por menos es
más y tenemos que se eliminan los
términos x al cuadrado y nos va a quedar
x menos cinco más uno es igual a menos 4
el resultado es x menos 4
así pues podemos reescribir esta
expresión que queremos integrar o
encontrar la derivada inversa y la
podemos escribir como 1 + x - 4
entre x cuadrada menos 1 y tratemos de
conservar los colores que usamos
originalmente y Bueno aquí ya tenemos un
grado menor en el numerador comparando
con el que tenemos en el denominador y
esta es bastante directo encontrar la
derivada inversa Pero bueno qué hacemos
ahora la derivada inversa de X al
cuadrado menos uno va a ser 2x y será el
mismo grado que esta de aquí arriba pero
no es un x menos 4 Así que aquí no vamos
a tener una sustitución directa qué
podemos hacer ahora pues ahora vamos a
usar otra herramienta en nuestra caja de
herramientas algebraicas lo que vamos a
hacer es hacer una expansión de
fracciones parciales esencialmente es
escribir esto como la suma de dos
expresiones racionales y que esas tengan
un grado menor en el denominador qué
quiero decir con esto Este término de
acá x menos 4 entre x cuadrada menos 1
lo podremos reescribir como x menos 4
entre Y en lugar de poner x cuadrada
menos podemos factorizar esto Esto es x
+ 1 por x menos 1 x + 1 * x - 1 y cuando
pensamos en la expansión de fracciones
parciales lo que hacemos Es decir bueno
puedo reescribir esto como la suma de
algo que todavía no sé que sea ese Algo
vamos a llamarlo a entre x + 1
sumado con algo más que no sea que sea
pero le voy a llamar B de momento entre
x - 1 podemos hacer esto Pues si nos
vemos tentados a hacerlo podemos sumar
estos dos y que nos daría deberíamos
encontrar un Común denominador que es x
+ 1 por x menos 1 así que lo que nos
queda Y si algo de esto les parece poco
familiar Los invito a que revisen los
vídeos de expansión de fracciones
parciales qué es lo que estamos haciendo
Aquí bueno Esto va a ser igual si
sumamos esto nuestro Común denominador
va a ser x + 1 x - 1
y para el primer término voy a
multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por x menos 1 así que aquí
arriba me queda a por x menos 1
más B que es el segundo término
multiplicado numerador y denominador por
x + 1 así que aquí nos queda B por x + 1
y qué es lo que nos queda Esto va a ser
igual a a x menos a más voy a
desarrollar esto de aquí y lo voy a
poner en este otro color esto es más BX
+ b y todo esto entre esto de acá y de
hecho Permíteme copiarlo y pegarlo que
es lo mismo que hemos estado escribiendo
así que tenemos esto entre esto y ahora
podemos agrupar los términos con x si
tomamos AX + BX será a más B todo esto
por x y ahora tenemos menos a más B más
B menos a y les voy a poner unos
paréntesis aquí para que me sea más
fácil agrupar estos dos y todo esto va a
estar dividido entre nuestro denominador
que aquí lo pego y aquí ya hemos
realizado la expansión de fracciones
parciales y desarrollamos todo esto para
probar que podemos hacerlo y si Existe
alguna a y b que cumpla con esto
entonces a más B debe ser el coeficiente
de nuestro término en x por lo que a más
B debe ser igual a uno que es este
coeficiente de aquí este uno y b menos a
debe ser igual a este término constante
a este menos cuatro y si existen pues ya
habremos encontrado nuestra a y b vamos
a hacerlo vamos a hacerlo aquí donde
tenemos un poco más de espacio a más B
será igual a 1 y menos a más B será
igual a -4 Y si sumamos el lado
izquierdo y también sumamos el lado
derecho nos va a dar que las has
desaparecen y aquí me queda dos b y dos
B va a ser igual a 1 - 4 va a ser igual
a menos 3 Así que B va a ser igual a
menos tres medios y aquí sabemos si
despejamos a de esta ecuación que a va a
ser igual a 1 - B ya conocemos B Así que
esto es igual a uno menos por menos es
más más tres medios lo que es igual a
cinco medios a es igual a cinco medios B
es igual a menos tres medios y así
podemos reescribir toda esta integral y
nos va a quedar de una manera que nos va
a facilitar encontrar la antiderivada o
lo que es lo mismo nos va a ser más
fácil de integrar va a ser la integral
de 1 + a
/ x + 1 encontramos que a es cinco
medios lo sustituimos aquí y nos va a
quedar lo escribimos así cinco medios
por uno entre x + 1 y lo escribo de esta
manera ya que la antiderivada de esto es
bastante directo y esto lo sumamos
nuestro término de B entre x menos 1
sustituimos B que encontramos que es
-3/2 así que aquí escribimos menos tres
medios por uno entre x menos 1 que es
esto de acá
y todo esto derivada de X noten que lo
único que hice fue tomar esto y con esta
expresión realicé la expansión de
fracciones parciales y como resultado
obtuve estos dos términos Y ahora esta
para integrar es bastante directa la
derivada inversa de uno de una constante
va a ser x la derivada inversa de cinco
medios por uno entre x + 1 será igual a
más cinco medios por el logaritmo
natural del valor absoluto de x + 1
pudimos hacer esto porque la derivada de
x + 1 es 1 es la derivada Así que
podemos tomar la antiderivada con
respecto a x + 1 y también podemos hacer
una sustitución como hemos hecho en
vídeos anteriores Y por acá vamos a
tener menos tres medios por el logaritmo
natural pero ahora de el valor absoluto
de x - 1 usamos exactamente la misma
lógica y por supuesto no podemos olvidar
nuestro término constante y aquí hemos
terminado pudimos integrar
pudimos evaluar esta expresión